Orlando Bloom in full bloom Katy Perry  had her man and his birthday suit all  right Orlando went full nude for  paddleboarding date with Katy on Tuesday  the pair was in Europe vacationing in  Corsica off the coast of Italy let's  keep it fun everybody's always wondering  Orlando hardly kept people wondering  he's also completely naked in this shot  but he is holding his swimsuit in his  hand and check out this pic bikini clad  Katy smooching Orlando this time he's  wearing his trunks it's all good the  lovebirds seem to be enjoying their  getaway and snap them strolling the  streets while in town and how cute is  Katy with her arm around her guy  nice everything's really crazy for the  boat